you don't mince words but you are
definitely not wrong at all right and I
think that's part of what we're seeing
right now is there was a lot of
financial engineering going on and when
you look out into the markets I mean how
long have people been saying hey we've
got over-leveraged companies in the
public markets you've got a pension
crisis you kind of got all these things
going on and actually the people who
were calling it out and and kind of most
aware of it were the people who aren't
inside the the system right they're not
in that legacy world that is kind of
blinded to all of this and so you need
those people to kind of check on reality
sometimes so pop I wanted to talk about
this going back to the stock the flow if
you don't mind I want to I want to talk
about an idea that I think is really
important I think when when we look at a
quote that Satoshi came up with let me
see if I can find it really fast
I apologize for the delay here is I'm
trying to find this on my phone but you
know early on Satoshi was talking about
ideas around how you would value Bitcoin
early on and he was talking about a
model that was very similar to mining
physical commodities and one of the
things that he talked about was this
exact model I'm trying to find the quote
here and I got this just for people to
know where I got this I got this quote
out of a book that's called the book of
Satoshi and it's a just a consolidated
list of all these direct quotes from
Satoshi I really like to study direct
quotes and not things that people are
you know well I think he said something
like this I want to read exactly the
verbage that that he came up with
whenever he said it I'm really
struggling to find the quote here hold
on one second uh find it on my phone but
let me let me just paraphrase it and
after I just said that I like to have
the exact quote let me paraphrase it but
if it's in - is is he talks about how
when you have something that's really
expensive
it incentivizes all those miners to go
in there and capture that price and then
whenever the price is getting punished
it they're they're not making money
because their cost is below that so they
start shutting down
well he's basically describing the exact
thing that we've all seen play out with
the Bitcoin price through the last 10
years and so what I find fascinating
about all this is is he was totally
expecting the price of Bitcoin to follow
and track very closely to the electrical
cost but what I think a lot of people
don't realize is that as more miners
come online and this difficulty
adjustment keeps ratcheting up almost
like a noose throughout that four-year
period this this four-year period then
throws in this shock this with the four
year having it throws this shock into
that stock the flow ramps it up just
like the model is showing and then all
the people that can't can't produce at
that at that price right if I'm a miner
and in the stock the flow just increased
at an exponential level to what I was
just accustomed to I'm now out of the
market I can't compete with the lowest
cost producers that are maybe getting
their their energy for free because
they're harnessing a waterfall or
whatever the case might be I drop out
and so does everybody else but then what
happens is you get that difficulty
adjustment that automatically allows
this to become competitive in the
marketplace and then the price
stabilizes it as it goes up there and
tries to approach it what I don't think
people realize is that these early on
this price was heavily tied to the
electrical costs and as time marches on
and you get more of these four year
cycles I I believe that the price
continues to be bound by that electrical
price but as you get more market
participants and more and more people
that pile onto it the upside of that is
not nearly as bound and you can get in a
point a point where you it's almost like
an orbital with like a spacecraft going
around an orbit if it just gets pushed a
little bit outside that orbit it can
actually completely separate from the
orbit and it goes off and then it
becomes
global money.i I think that's exactly
what we're seeing playing out and I kind
of believe that this next four your
having cycle combined with all the
things that we're seeing globally with
these debt markets just getting totally
the based and totally manipulated might
be that final push that kind of kicks it
out of the orbit that it's going in and
so as we look at the may having that's
coming up and you're seeing the stock
the flow models showing that it should
be around a hundred thousand somewhere
in that ballpark
right and it's not gonna it's not gonna
get there within the first well it'll
probably get up to that level within a
year this according to the model and
maybe even go higher but I think as it
pushes higher and you get all this
global adoption and then you have market
caps that are in excess of trillions of
dollars I think you're gonna have
traditional finance years that are
looking at this and saying alright
clearly this is this is something that
is not going away
this is this thing has been pronounced
dead 150 times at this point and it's
clearly not dead and I'm seeing that the
basement that's happening and I think
that as you as you push this thing up
and pass the trillion and you start
getting this buy and you get all these
various vehicles that are allowing
people to capture the underlying price
through financial derivatives or
whatever and I don't know necessarily
know if I would call that what's at gbtc
a financial derivative but I would
vehicles like that are gonna enable this
thing to kind of bump out of that that
stock to flow price that's being held in
there by this two-week difficulty
adjustment combined with the four you're
having when you when you put those two
together I'll use a military reference
so and there's a great movie scene that
that exemplifies what I'm talking about
so if you ever watched the start of
gladiator and you have the long bows
right the the archers the long bows they
shoot their their their long bows and
then you have all the Calvary that's
that's flank and going up the
around the backside they don't see him
because their heads are down and they're
trying the enemies they're trying to
protect themselves from those longbow
shots that are coming in so they got
their head down they're hunkered down
they're trying to protect themselves and
as they're doing that that Calvary of
all the the horsemen are going up around
the side around the flank where they
can't see them and then as soon as those
longbow stop firing they come in they're
on a fast attack fast assault and they
and they go to battle and they catch
them by surprise on their side what I
think you have there your long bows and
I'm using this military reference people
might hate it but I love it they're
using the long bows that's your for your
having cycle that's the thing that comes
at you when you just think it's so far
out there that it's not correlated at
all to a two-week difficulty adjustment
but then after that longbow has been
fired with that four year having cycle
the two-week difficulty adjustment or
your that's your Calvary that's coming
in and it's just annihilating the living
heck out of the speculators and so
there's those miners that are going in
there and that are mining this that are
ratcheting up that are trying to capture
that price premium that is that occurs
immediately after that for your having
cycle all those speculators come in they
bid the price astronomically highway
above the stock the flow and then the
2-week difficulty adjustment just keeps
grinding it back down to where it needs
to be so why did why did Satoshi do all
why did he design it this way okay
because I'm describing something that's
that's saying that the price needs to be
fixed at that level
for a four year period before you go
into another price bump and then it
needs to be fixed at that intrinsic
value for another four year period why
did he design it this way my humble
opinion of why he designed it this way
is because he needed entrenchment he
needed people to not he needed this
thing to not take off in four years
because he knows there would be too much
drama around it and that you wouldn't
have the entrenchment into the existing
financial rails in order to stop it but
if you can push this thing out over a
decade
well then you can get you can get tons
of volatility people are gonna write it
off as being nothing more than a
speculators tool right that's that's
what the crazy people go in and trade
because the volatility is over sixty
percent annually so only only idiots are
doing that and so you'd have governments
you'd have very wealthy individuals that
would just write it off as being nothing
more than a speculators game but yet the
thing keeps trucking along and it keeps
bumping its price up purely for the
reason to capture and in work its way in
as a Trojan horse into the existing
financial rails that's my theory what
would have to happen for you to think
either one the bitcoin thesis is no
longer valid or to something in your
theory is inaccurate so I've been asked
this before and I think that the the
concern that I have is that early on my
concern was that it could be banned and
that a government could step in and do
something to it they could stop it I
don't necessarily have that concern
anymore I think that what we've seen
globally there are countries like
Germany there's other countries that are
absolutely open arms wide open to this
thing in fact I would argue any country
that's dealt with doll or dominance over
that last 80 years which is every
country has felt the pain of what that's
like did not be a reserve currency and
they're looking at this is maybe being
something especially country and I think
this is why it's so popular in Germany
is because they they remember it's in
there it's in the deep cultural roots
the 1920 hyperinflation event with the
with the mark that they remember that
culturally they know how that played out
and they don't ever want to see it again
so they look at fiscal spending a lot
different than I think a lot of
countries in the world and so they're
looking at this and saying this makes a
whole lot of sense so as long as you
have countries like that it's never
gonna get shut down and that's what a
shutdown needs is for everybody to agree
that it needs to be banned and I don't
see that happening so that was my
original
I would say now it could be you know the
price could go down you could see a lot
of psych psychology maybe push it lower
if you had minors that I think this
would be a concern if you had minors
that started really pulling their rigs
offline and they were not in the
business of swapping Fiat for payments
in BTC the stuff into their Treasury on
their balance sheet I think that would
be a concern and we have pretty much
seen the exact opposite of that and I
think you're always I guess my personal
pain is you're always gonna see the
exact opposite opposite of that for one
reason and it's the difficulty
adjustment look at what we're going
through right now the price got hammered
right and there are many minors that
that became unprofitable because of this
derivative movement that we've just seen
but guess what the incoming two-week
difficulty adjustment that's due here in
a couple days it's dropping 15% to make
it more accommodative for them to come
back online and boost that price right
back up to the intrinsic value it's all
by design I mean this the game theory on
this thing is nuts and Here I am trying
to tell you how it could fail and I'm
still coming up with freaking reasons of
why I don't think it's gonna fail
because I've tried my darndest to come
up with all the reasons of why this
thing won't work and all I can arrive at
based on the game theory is that it is
gonna work yeah the only thing that you
didn't say that I answer the question
with is a self-induced bug so from a
developer standpoint there's something
that's introduced to the codebase that
could be like a self-inflicted wound
obviously given the development process
I think that's highly unlikely but I'm
with you in that there's just not very
much externally that I think is a threat
at this point and so when you go to is
kind of the self-inflicted stuff well I
love that point I think that's a great
risk to highlight you know and when we
look back at the summer of 2017 with
Jeff garsik
right remember Jeff did something really
goofy there right at the last minute
that could have really compromised a lot
with just the trust and confidence in
the in the protocol um I think that
could play out I I don't know if if that
plays out that the code can be adjusted
people can go back in there they can
they can adjust the code right the
protocol and those transactions or the
the the basically the stoppage that you
would see throughout that period or
they're going back to it make that
adjustment
I think you'd lose a lot of trust for
some people that are coin holders in the
protocol now would that trust go
somewhere else I don't necessarily know
that that it would long-term it might
short term but I think is all systems
come back online I think that you would
have not everybody come back in but I
think you'd have a lot that would show
back up and they would they would
stabilize the market but I don't
necessarily know if it would cause this
this loss and trust spiral that would
take it down to zero I don't think
you're ever gonna get that because this
difficulty adjustment is in the four
year having cycle is going to ensure
that this eventually becomes global
money